يبدو ان العربي اتخذ خطوات عده لتصعيد ولا
جديده في هذا
[موسيقى]
الهدف من هذا الاستفزاز هو اتهام روسيا
باستخدام اسلحه الدمار الشامل في اوكرانيا
والاطلاق حمله قويه تهدف الى تقويض الثقه
في موسكو
من فرمته
لدينا معلومات محدده حول تلك المؤسسات في
اوكرانيا التي لديها التقنيه لصناعه هذه
القنبله القذره للغايه ان هذا ليس شكا لقد
اتخذنا الخطوات اللازمه لاثاره هذه القضيه
في المنابر الدوليه
راس او راس الصاروخ بماده مشعه من اليورين
المنظم فاصل ثلاثه بالعشره بالميه من
الطاقه الاشعاعيه لليورانيوم المخصب تقسيم
عالي وبالتالي عندما يتم الانفجار تكون
حشوه تقليديه تنفجر يتطاير الغبار الذري
يغطي مساحه معينه
[موسيقى]
اذا كانت روسيا تقول ان اوكرانيا بصدد
التحضير لامر ما فهذا يعني امرا واحدا ان
روسيا سبق ان اعدت كل ذلك اعتقد انه ينبغي
على العالم ان يرد باقصى قدر ممكن
[موسيقى]
روسيا اقترفت الكثير من الجرائم جرائم
الحرب ضد اوكرانيا واستدفت البناء التحتيه
والسادفت المدنيين وهذا طبعا يجعل من حياه
المدنيين صعبه